does society become unstable when
there's no one at the table a new study
bemoans the social cost of eating alone
The Wall Street Journal owned by our
parent company Elmer's Glue
talk about tasty points out how we're
spending less time being social and more
time being alone it was a great article
I read it while eating dinner over the
kitchen sink
oh in fact time spent talking to other
people has been in Decline for nearly 30
years and we're falling further and
further away from one another the main
reason humans are exhausting to which
Kilmeade replied so it's not just me
thank you
the author writes that interaction takes
work and when given the choice it's
easier to be alone than dealing with
others it makes sense think of the
effort it takes to meet new people
there's the stalking the crouching
behind bushes carrying that bag of zip
ties and duct tape
but the downside lost Innovation and
creativity and people less willing to
see other points of view that disconnect
can lead to mental illness substance
abuse and worse watching Seth Meyers
I know I know it is sad one poll
illustrates this trend at the dinner
table a survey found that the average
person spends just three meals a week
with loved ones the rest of the time
it's with their family
[Laughter]
but have said having dinner together is
important way to connect that's what my
dad used to say every time we went
through the Burger King drive-through
I just wish we had been in a car
but it's like my uncle used to say
loneliness could be the least favorite
thing about life and I wish I could have
hugged him but he wouldn't loosen the
restraints
wow yeah
Terence uh how do you do you buy this
kind of I mean the sentiment that we're
spending less time with other people and
we're retreating into like kind of our
own caves well I spent less time with my
liberal cousins and siblings yeah
crazy oh you know but you know what I
think people are spending less time at
the dinner table I think you know I
think everybody is mourning the loss of
Aunt Jemima
I think they're more than the loss of
Aunt jemama but I want everybody know
you know I created my own pancake mix
called cousin T's so they can have those
now
don't you have your own pancake yes
cousin cheese Pancakes yes yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know uh Tyrus I think that that the
fact it's weird how people I think are
less social with their family than they
are with people outside their family
right yeah well you the dinner table now
you have to compete with everybody being
on their phone yeah which I don't
tolerate you know if you've ever seen
that planet AIDS movie where he slams
his fists on the table no phones you
know and they're like so then they put
the they put the phones away and then
you just hear like the sound of
silverware and a plate that clink clink
clink yes the clink clink and then I
just say take your phones and leave just
go just go I'm home for two days I don't
want to talk to you anyway just go no no
no no Roblox is more important go I get
it your Facebook form you might miss one
of your fake carrots growing in so just
go
and then they come back like Dad I'm
sorry like well at least sit down and
eat that's it that's at least you get it
back you know they have no choice I they
live in my house
cat could it be that with so many people
on the planet alone time becomes more
precious
not to me no
I don't like being by myself but I don't
have a family or a kitchen table
I know what you mean so it's not like
it's meal time with my family because
you know that couldn't be real but I
don't I don't I don't buy this at least
for myself like I love to be around
other people and if I'm ever finding
myself alone I immediately am like okay
who's gonna hang out with me because
otherwise it's just you and your
thoughts yeah
the thoughts are your enemy the thoughts
are always so mean to me yeah they're
always trying to question no you know
what they're oh their thoughts are
always trying to get you to think about
the stuff that happened before and the
stuff that's about to happen and it
never is right here and it's never like
oh this great stuff that happened and I
did it's like this stuff that you did
that was awful and then you know what
could go wrong yeah yeah I just want to
eat I don't care who I'm eating with I
just want to eat
[Applause]
to be
[Applause]
are you I'm amazed how you can get
Applause with just the simplest things
it's amazing they like eating
but it's because she's so lovable
it really is it's when short goes right
[Applause]
that was a jab at me
so Carly did you spend with your family
uh when I was growing up yeah yes so
it's not not so it's well now I mean I
work I essentially work overnights um
and I live by myself do you have a table
no exactly this is a New York City thing
so I I literally do sometimes eat dinner
over the kitchen sink which is a set yes
you're really tall you're really tall
for the food just like if you spill it
it just like takes forever to hit the
sink not like a horse
I do have to say though I like the idea
of plans because this is also like
people are making less plans but then
when the day comes you're just like oh
God please cancel is that funny yeah I
look forward to it usually I make plans
when I'm a little drunk and when I wake
up the next day I'm like I don't want to
do this that was the best part of the
pandemic to be honest because everything
you had on your calendar for the whole
year that you didn't want to do
automatically canceled I have a solution
can we show my little friend so I just I
got a pet that's in my office and here
he is where's my little friend there he
is that's uh that's Abe Vigoda isn't he
great all you got does is he just stares
at me like that while I'm writing and
I'm telling you it is like a hundred uh
like it's like night and day I get
hypnotized by that little fella and he
can't be with other people right Tyrus
no he wants to eat you yeah
she looks at me all day
isn't he great so that's what you need
you just need a little what's that a
Parrotfish yes thank you I love fried
fish
that was exactly yeah he's like the most
economical Applause meter
three words I love fish
up next teens left to their own devices
has Six Flags raising prices hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else